Was das Licht anleuchtet, wird sichtbar. Wir
sehen also nicht das Ding selbst,
sondern nur die Strahlen,
die von ihm reflektiert werden.
Ich reflektiere, also bin ich?
Überall leuchtet es. Licht ist allgegenwärtig.
Aber was ist Licht für ein seltsamer Stoff? Ist
es überhaupt ein Stoff?
Oder reine Energie?
Licht ist uns nur scheinbar vertraut –
Photonen, Lichtteilchen, öffnen die Tore zu
einer völlig seltsamen Welt.
Früher dachte man, kleine Kügelchen
schwirren durch die Gegend.
Dann hielt man Licht für eine Welle. Heute
weiß man:
Je nachdem, welche Experimente man
anstellt,
ist es mal das eine und mal das andere.
Licht ist ’ne Welle.
Andererseits: Licht ist ’n Teilchen.
Und je nachdem, wie ich’s beobachte,
ist es irgendwie beides.
Beides gleichzeitig.
Das ist auch richtig bizarr.
Es kann ja nicht nur bizarr sein, das Licht. Es
ist schließlich da.
Man sieht es im wahrsten Sinne des Wortes
ja dauernd.
Aber wenn man genauer hinguckt, sieht man
praktisch nichts mehr.
Spätestens dann, wenn man versucht, ein
Photon auf die Waage zu legen …
Ja, das ist wirklich auf den ersten Blick etwas
merkwürdig.
Also wir, ich sitze hier auf dem Stuhl
und habe natürlich dann
eine bestimmte Masse.
Wenn jetzt hier eine Waage wäre,
das wäre dann meine Ruhemasse.
Und das gilt auch für Elementarteilchen wie
das Photon
und das Neutron, das Elektron, aus denen wir
ja auch bestehen.
Nun, beim Photon ist das anders, es hat
tatsächlich Ruhemasse Null!
Also ist es da und gleichzeitig doch nicht da?
Das Photon ist aber nie in Ruhe, sagen die
Physiker, sondern bewegt sich ständig.
Und natürlich nicht irgendwie, sondern mit
Lichtgeschwindigkeit –
wo die nächste Merkwürdigkeit steckt.
Auf den ersten Blick ist das Licht einfach nur
schnell, wenn man es auf die Reise schickt.
In 1,3 Sekunden bis zum Mond
oder in einer Sekunde
siebenmal um die Erde herum.
Hebt man den Blick Richtung Kosmos, klingt
das gar nicht mehr so doll.
Denn bis zum Saturn,
dem fernsten Planeten, den man in unserem
Sonnensystem
noch mit dem bloßem Auge sieht, braucht das
Licht schon anderthalb Stunden.
Oder bis zum nächsten Stern: vier Jahre!
Und bis zur Andromeda-Galaxie braucht es
ganz ordentliche 4,5 Millionen Jahre!
300.000 Kilometer pro Sekunde:
Das ist nicht irgendeine Geschwindigkeit.
Mehr geht nicht. Unter keinen Umständen.
Das Licht aus einem Scheinwerfer wird nicht
das geringste bisschen schneller,
wenn sich das Auto zusätzlich bewegt.
Braucht es auch nicht.
Licht bewegt sich immer
mit Lichtgeschwindigkeit.
Und ich kann das nicht addieren.
Das hat aber sofort, wenn man darüber – na
ja – ’ne halbe Stunde nachdenkt,
die Konsequenz, dass die Zeit nicht immer
gleich schnell vergeht.
Dank Einstein, der allerdings mehr als eine
halbe Stunde brauchte,
wissen wir, dass Raum und Zeit sich
verzerren, wenn wir uns bewegen.
Je schneller wir unterwegs sind, desto stärker
ist die Verzerrung.
Und das Photon bewegt sich mit 300.000
Kilometern pro Sekunde sehr schnell.
Die Verzerrung ist bei dieser Geschwindigkeit
so extrem,
dass die Zeit aus der Sicht des Photons
stillsteht
und der Raum keine Ausdehnung mehr hat.
Schneller wäre also sinnlos…
Perspektive des Photons:
Das Universum hat keine Ausdehnung mehr.
Ich bin überall im Universum gleichzeitig.
Jetzt können wir uns leider in die
Photon-Perspektive nicht versetzen –
das wär ja ’ne tolle Nummer, wenn wir dem
zugucken könnten
und die Perspektive auch hätten –,
weil leider jeder Körper, der ’ne Masse hat,
jeder Körper, der schwer ist,
der Gewicht hat, braucht unendlich viel
Energie,
um auf Lichtgeschwindigkeit zu kommen.
Das Photon wäre was sehr, na ja, sehr
Exotisches.
Also, es hätte dann eigentlich keinen Raum
und keine Zeit.
Kein Wunder, dass Licht Besinnlichkeit stiftet.
Mein Umgang mit Licht ist schon noch
alltagstauglich.
Aber dass Licht auf ’ner Ebene geheimnisvoll
ist,
die jetzt nicht mystisch oder romantisch ist,
das begleitet mich schon durchaus.
Natürlich, manchmal,
vielleicht in einem ruhigen Augenblick,
oder wenn man
eben gerade entspannt,
natürlich, klar überlege ich mir, wie bettet
sich jetzt das ein,
was ich jetzt hier jeden Tag mache in
eigentlich die grundlegenden Gleichungen,
die grundlegenden Gesetze der Natur.
Das Licht erinnert eben
an die tiefsten Rätsel der Welt.
Nicht nur auf den Altären vieler Religionen,
sondern auch in den geschmeidigen
Gehirnen der Physiker.